Life is full of unbelievable events of great
synchronicity.
Are there really people whom can predict the
future?
Is there a benevolent force at play?
Or is it simply just the law of large numbers.
Whatever it is, there's no denying that there
have been countless, spookily accurate predictions
made throughout history that have come true.
Let's take a look at the all time most amazingly
accurate predictions.
1.
We start with a woman named Elena Sheppard
who, in 2013 predicted, with 100% accuracy
all the winners of the upcoming Golden Globe
awards.
PolicyMic is a political and cultural news
website and forum that launched in 2011.
In January 201, their culture editor Elena
Sheppard was assigned to report on the upcoming
Golden Globe awards.
She pulled of an amazing feat of speculation.
She accurately predicted which TV programmes
and films would take home each of the 25 awards.
She got all 25 correct and they weren't no
brainers either, many of the wins were taken
by unexpected nominees.
2.
On Febuary 11th 2013 a woman tweeted that
her boyfriend told her about a dream in which
the current Pope, Benedict XVI (16th) resigned
and a man named Francesco replaced him.
No more than 17 days later and sure enough
Pope Benedict announced his retirement and
Pope Francis took his place.
The tweet was in Spanish, but the translation
reads "My boyfriend woke up last night at
4 a.m. saying he had dreamed of a new pope
called 'Francis I' and that today Benedict
will resign."
Also, just as astonishing, in 2010, 3 years
before Pope Francis came into the spotlight.
A lawyer named Christopher Connors registered
the domain name PopeFrancis.com.
When the press asked him why he registered
the domain name he refused to comment.
3.
The American TV comedy scrubs is probably
the last place you would expect to find mind
blowing predictions about the future.
But in a 2006 episode, the janitor makes an
eerie comment to J.D.
He said "In my opinion, we should be looking
for Bin Laden in Pakistan."
Sure enough, 5 years later U.S. soldiers found
Bin Laden hiding in a heavily guarded house
in Pakistan.
4.
Mark Twain was an American author, but what
many people don't know about him is that he
remarkably predicted the internet.
In 1898, Mark Twain wrote a short story called
"From The 'London Times' in 1904" he described
an invention called the "telectroscope" which
used the phone system to create a world wide
network for sharing information.
Which is basically the internet.
Keep in mind that he wrote this when telephones
were still very new.
It is also written in his story "the daily
doings of the globe made visible to everybody,
and audibly discussable too, by witnesses
separated by any number of leagues."
yep that's right, Mark Twain also predicted
social networking.
But that's not all Mark Twain predicted.
He also predicted his own death.
Halley's Comet is visible from Earth every
75 years.
Mark Twain was born in 1835 when Halley's
Comet was visible in the sky and he predicted
that he would die the next time Halley's Comet
is visible.
Sure enough he died 75 years later in 1910
just as Halley's Comet was visible again.
5.
Next up is a man who predicted many of today's
modern technologies 100 years in advance.
A relatively unknown Civil Engineer, John
Elfreth Watkins made a number of predictions
in the year 1900 about what the world would
be like in the year 2000.
He wrote an article in a woman's magazine
called Ladies' Home Journal entitled "What
May Happen in the Next Hundred Years".
His article began with the words "These prophecies
will seem strange, almost impossible".
He then proceeded to discuss a handful of
future technologies in great detail.
Most of it was remarkably accurate.
Here's some of the things he predicted that
came true.
Digital colour photography, mobile phones,
ready meals, television and tanks.
Here's an interesting snippet of what he wrote
in his prediction about digital colour photography:
"Photographs will be telegraphed from any
distance.
If there be a battle in China a hundred years
hence, snapshots of its most striking events
will be published in the newspapers an hour
later....
photographs will reproduce all of nature's
colours."
6.
Next up is Robert Heinlein, whom predicted
the Cold War, 7 years before it started.
Heinlein was a science fiction author and
in 1940 he wrote a short story called "Solution
Unsatisfactory", in which he depicted a United
States that develops a nuclear weapon before
the rest of the world, becoming the foremost
superpower and igniting a nuclear arms race
amongst the rest of the world.
It was a perfect description of what happened
years later in the events that led up to the
start of the Cold War in 1947.
7.
Next up, and on somewhat of a similar note,
English writer H.G. Wells predicted the conception
of the atomic bomb 31 years before it was
actually invented.
Not an easy task when you consider the complexity
of such an invention.
In H.G. Wells' 1914 novel "The World Set Free",
Wells wrote about a city-destroying atomic
bomb that could explode continuously using
the power of radioactivity.
8.
Tana Hoy is an American psychic who claims
to be able to hear spirits and predict the
future.
During 1995, Hoy was doing a live radio programme
in North Carolina when he predicted, on air,
a deadly terrorist attack against a federal
building in Oklahoma City.
90 minutes later, a bomb was detonated at
the Alfred P. Murrah Federal Building in downtown
Oklahoma City, which killed 168 people.
It was at the time the worst ever terrorist
attack on U.S. soil.
9.
In 1949, English novelist George Orwell published
his dystopian novel 1984, which talks about
people being constantly monitored by closed-circuit
security cameras.
When the book was first published people would
have quickly dismissed the idea that CCTV
cameras and constant surveillance would ever
be a reality.
But as we all know that's not quite how things
panned out, we are now watched everywhere
we go by CCTV, just like in George Orwell's
classic novel.
Ironically George Orwell's home country, England
is now the world's most watched nation.
The United Kingdom has 1% of the world's population
but 20% of it's CCTV cameras, that's one camera
for every 14 people.
10.
In 2010 the football world cup was in full
swing and a German octopus named Paul became
an unlikely celebrity overnight when he correctly
predicted the winners of 11 upcoming world
cup matches.
Paul lived in a tank at an aquarium in Germany,
aquarium staff put two boxes filled with food
into his tank, each with the flag of a different
country on it whom were competing against
each other in an upcoming match.
Paul would make his prediction by eating from
the box of the winning team.
He successfully predicted the outcomes of
11 out of 13 games.
After the World Cup finished Paul went on
to successfully predict the outcomes of basketball
and American football games.
11.
Next up is Edgar Cayce, perhaps one of the
most well known psychics of the 20th century,
he earned himself the nickname "The Sleeping
Prophet" because he would deliver psychic
readings to people and make incredibly accurate
predictions whilst in a self-induced hypnotic
state.
Cayce correctly predicted countless future
events, but his most notable predictions that
came true are: He predicted the collapse of
the Soviet Union, the Stock Market Crash and
the Great Depression, the rise and fall of
Adolf Hitler and last but not least he predicted
the deaths of not one but two US presidents,
Franklin D. Roosevelt and John F. Kennedy.
12.
Australian based Jeffry R. Palmer is a well
known psychic, whose predictions are somewhat
hit and miss, but the handful of correct predictions
he has made have been strikingly accurate.
Palmer accurately predicted the Indian Ocean
volcano eruption of December 26th 2004, he
also predicted that Korea was testing nuclear
weapons.
But his most notable predictions was correctly
predicting the 2005 Hurricane Katrina, that
claimed 1,836 lives.
13.
Next up are the freakishly accurate predictions
of French novelist Jules Verne.
He successfully predicted a whole range of
future technologies and events in his writings,
such as electric submarines, newscasts and
video conferencing.
But his most notable prediction was that of
the moon landing.
In Verne's 1865 novel, From the Earth to the
Moon, which was written over 100 years before
America's mission to the moon.
Verne described, with eerily accurate detail,
a space mission to the moon.
In Verne's story a manned spaceship was launched
from Florida, in the month of December, both
of these facts perfectly align with the real
mission, over 100 years later.
Verne also managed to predict the name of
the Apollo 11 command module, which was named
Columbia.
And that they would become weightless once
they entered space, which he should not have
known at the time he wrote the book.
14.
Next up is American author and inventor Ray
Kurzweil.
He has made several predictions about future
technologies over the past decades, and an
astonishing 86% of them have come true.
Kurzweil predicted the fall of the Soviet
Union, computers beating humans at chess by
the year 2000 and wireless internet becoming
widely available in the 21st century.
He also predicted nanotechnology, face recognition
software and e-books.
Kurzweil has also predicted that within 15
years from now humans will crack the code
of immortality and people's life spans will
start rapidly increasing.
15.
And finally, you can't possibly talk about
this subject without mentioning the extraordinary
Michel de Nostredame, more commonly known
as simply Nostradamus.
During the 14th century Nostradamus published
over 1,000 predictions for the future, and
historians have now deemed that over half
of them have come true.
He predicted the coming of three anti-Christs
in his writings, what he wrote about each
anti-Christ closely matches up to the lives
of Napoleon, Hitler and Saddam Hussein.
His writings about Adolf Hitler included the
lines:
"Out of the deepest part of the west of Europe,
From poor people a young child shall be born,
Who with his tongue shall seduce many people,
His fame shall increase in the Eastern Kingdom."
Hitler was indeed born to poor parents and
used his tongue to seduce many people to do
his evil bidding.
Nostradamus even predicted that Hitler would
die alone.
Nostradamus also wrote about an event that
bares extremely close to the 9/11 attacks
against America.
He wrote:
"The sky will burn at forty-five degrees.
Fire approaches the great new city."
Experts agree that the great new city at forty-five
degrees can only refer to New York city which
is near 45 degrees latitude.
Nostradamus also predicted among many others,
JFK's assassination, the atomic bomb, the
French Revolution and the Great Fire of London.